[THEME MUSIC]
JASON SILVA: So I've been
thinking a lot lately
of the Quantified
Self Revolution.
You've heard the buzz term.
And it's this idea that
as we extend computation
into everything, as we extend
sensors into everything,
we're increasingly extending
those sensors into ourselves.
Creating a data-rich,
always-on stream of information
about our biological
functionings,
all the metrics that
we use to measure
how this system of
biology is operating
are now getting
fed into a machine.
And we're pooling the data
from millions of people,
eventually finding
patterns in the data,
learning how to optimize
the way the data is managed,
feeding that information
back into ourselves,
transforming what it means
to be a human being running
in a optimum capacity.
And this just excites
me a lot, because it's
this idea that just like we can
soup up our cars to get more
performance out of
them, imagine how
these insights into
ourselves might transform
the possibilities.
We can sort of play around
with our biochemical matrix.
We can literally
rev ourselves up
to ways we could have
never conceived before.
This could be the
beginning of human 2.0.
Right?
[THEME MUSIC]